the national insurance rise is a
significant change to our tax system but
what will it mean for you well there's
two key things we need to consider
firstly this the national insurance rate
is going up it means everything you earn
over the threshold was being taxed at 12
it'll now be taxed at 13.25
that might sound small but it's a
sizable tax rise take for example
someone earning 27 000 pounds a year
that person was paying around 2053
pounds in national insurance annually
that will go up by over 200 pounds a
year however given the cost of living
crisis the chancellor was under huge
pressure to relieve some of the burden
on people so he's made another
adjustment a move to the national
insurance threshold it's essentially the
amount we can all earn before that tax
kicks in so from july that's going up to
12
570 pounds it's essentially a tax cut
worth about 330 pounds a year so what
does all this mean how do those two
things balance out against each other
well have a look at this this shows the
impact of just the national insurance
rate rise it shows how much different
people will pay look across the bottom
here those are all the different annual
earnings that people have and as you can
see on this alone everyone above the
threshold will be paying more the
highest earners over this way paying the
most as that line comes down but look
what happens once we include that tax
threshold move from july essentially
everyone earning under 32 000 pounds a
year will actually be better off look
how that line rises up there above zero
once these two things are factored in
together around two million lower
earners will actually be taken out of
the tax altogether now remember this
plan was to help fund the new health and
social care levy so does all this mean
that the nhs will be getting less well
not quite and that's because wages are
going up so the treasury's actually
forecast to make more from these taxes
than expected that's the blue bars that
we've got there in fact it actually just
about cancels out what the government is
losing by raising that tax threshold the
red bars that you can see below there
and how that changes over time and i
just want to leave you with this taking
into account all the tax changes this
year the tax burden is actually still
very high this shows the impact when we
split the population into 20 parts by
income so although the tax is very
progressive you can see over here the
richest people paying proportionally
much more over here you can see it
really is only the very poorest
households who won't be left worse off
as a result of these changes it may
still feel like a very difficult and
expensive time for many